yang speaks is sponsored by expressvpn
why haven't you gotten a vpn yet visit
expressvpn.com
yang
these aren't these aren't companies we
buy stuff from they're companies who
create the places in which we live and
that's a very different dynamic than
like somebody who
you know i'm buying pants from when when
it's uh when it's
in many ways the the spaces on which
uh the the public discourse is had
and in places in which i sort of feel
like i live my life you
said it in a really profound way it's
like this is where you live
now you know like this is how you're
experiencing the world
this is how you're developing your point
of view
we're gonna eventually realize that
these companies
are more than companies and in a way
they are their own governments
you know sort of totalitarian
autocracies
like capitalist autocracy emperor
presiding over his 2.2 billion
yeah subjects say today
you will see this and you will like it
and it will be good
[Music]
it is my distinct pleasure to welcome to
yang speaks
the alpha creative novelist
original v educator logger millions
mr hank green welcome hank hello thank
you so much for having me on your
podcast
i i'm excited to have you because i
gotta say when i was
looking at your exploits i was like oh
my gosh like how did one man
produce so much content over this period
without
losing his gourd and perhaps the most
impressive thing about it to me
is is the novelist part where you have
a second book that's coming out next
week
uh called i believe a beautifully
foolish endeavor that's correct
and to me this is the most creative uh
or most impressive because
to write a full-fledged book and then
another book on top of everything else
you're doing just seems to me to be
such a daunting task uh you know unless
you're a dad on top of it you've got
like a boy who's turning four this year
i believe
and i know what that's like i mean
you know just like whirling dervishes of
of energy
uh he's great yes
so yeah just tell us about your book
because it seems like a really
great veiled commentary on some of the
biggest issues of our time
despite the fact that it's a novel
directed primarily at young people i get
the sense
um i i don't feel like it's a young
person book in any particular way that
the main characters are in their 20s
um the first book they're they're just
out of college the second book they're
a little older so i thought of myself i
thought it to myself as like y
a yeah you like dig me
for that though it seems much more
elevated intellectually
yeah and i definitely like i i want it
to be accessible to to those people
because i think that they
are gonna be making a lot of the
decisions that are gonna
like basically be the ones that really
truly decide what the internet is going
to be
and uh and that even i you know someone
who when i was
first you know i got my first email
address when i was in high school
very different lifestyle for the kids
now who are on tick tock
and um you know i do not really know how
i
write find time to write a book because
it is like a huge amount of time that
goes into the thing
um but it's really rewarding and a
really interesting way to look
at at like the big hard problems that
i don't really know how to interface
with every day
and the both of the books are sort of
near future science fiction um the world
is different than
than our world but in most ways it is
the same
and you know the first book was really
an attempt
to like like for me to like
examine and and come to terms with
how the internet can affect individuals
and has affected me
and like what this kind of low-level new
kind of internet
celebrity means what should be done with
it how should it be thought of how
should it be treated
and then the second book i was able to
go much broader and
sort of ask bigger questions about what
is what do these platforms mean for
everyone for for the world for society
for culture
and for our future and really wanted it
to be a look at what i i
you know worry the world might look like
in
five or ten years as these platforms
continue to amass a lot of power
well that is front of mind for many
people right now where you have
this major advertiser boycott of
facebook
commencing in july that includes
coca-cola
unilever i think pepsi just joined some
of the biggest
advertisers in the world are saying hold
up there's something going on
with facebook that we are not happy
about
uh and so i think the issues you're
identifying
uh are super central and relevant
right now and i would love to to unpack
them with you
because i've been attacking the same
problems from a policy perspective
it's like the that we can see that there
are these trends that are developing or
that are here with us right now
that are really negative for our
democracy
for our mental health for the
economic incentives of how we receive
and process information
absolutely and and that and the the
impact
is tearing us apart in various ways
it's making our kids anxious and
depressed
uh it's making it so that we can't trust
each other or what we're seeing or
reading
so if you have something that should be
completely apolitical let's call it
wearing masks during a pandemic
that somehow yeah now we're capable of
politicizing
any yeah any stance at all
it's like well you may think we should
wear masks but i don't think we should
and my perspective is just as good as
you can yeah and
and not only is it just as good but it's
like so vital
and we have to fight for it and if we
did if we let that right be
to not wear a mask be taken away from us
then that's the end of
like my desire to even be an american
anymore
it's it's it's wild it you know it's
interesting because the first book was
written
basically to to create a stand-in for
something that would be politicized and
that something in the book is
you know not something that exists in in
our world but
um but was immediately politicized was
immediately had sort of like one
set of values and and one political like
part of the political spectrum
latched on to feeling one way about it
and treating it one way and another way
another group treating it you know
basically the opposite way
and the main character kind of loves the
fact that she gets to be drawn
into this debate and become influential
and she gets to be a pundit and she gets
to yell about it on cable news
and she like finds her nemeses and she
fights against them and for her
even though this stuff is like deeply
vitally important to the human race
it's just fun for her a lot of the time
and that's how she's thinking about it
she's like she's thinking day to day not
about like
how to make the world better but how to
get more views
and how to get more engagement and how
to how to win
the game and i feel like far too many
people right now feel like we were
playing a game
when you know hundreds of thousands of
people are dying
i ran for president as you know uh and
there was a time when it felt like there
are game mechanics at play
during the campaign yeah when i called
it out as a reality tv show
at one point on the debates but then i
was still participating in the reality
tv show
and for me it hit home when i did
something that was totally random where
i was in south carolina
and there were there's a jazzercise
class and there were women
doing the cupid shuffle and then not
wanting to be rude i was like okay
like let let me do it with you and just
uh have some fun
and i literally forgot that we had like
a journalist in tow
um at the time who just took the video
on their phone
and then it wound up and then to me
shockingly people
gave a [ __ ] about me doing the cupid
shuffle
such that it went around the
social media landscape and then it went
to mainstream news
where i was part of like uh i did a
sunday morning
network tv appearance and they used that
as like my intro
clip um where it's like here's andrew
yeah he's having fun on the trail
and i was like what the hell is going on
where
where yeah i'm literally running out
this whole big set of ideas that
obviously like you know i i think's
vitally important for
our nation's future and it's like but
that doesn't matter you know what
matters like you
yeah cupid shuffling uh in south
carolina
yeah and i i mean i think that there's i
think there's like some legitimacy to
this
and you've talked about it a little bit
on the podcast before that
you know people believe stories and like
we want to find stories that we fit into
and we want to find stories that other
people fit into and so if
if you know that's kind of a lot of what
politics is is like trying to
tell a story around your opponent and
tell a story around yourself
and make those the most compelling
stories and more compelling than their
stories
because and like this is a shame to some
extent
but but also you know this is a
democracy
and most people do not have anything
like the amount of time that you and i
have to think about this stuff
and so we need simplifying stories we
need ways
for people to be engaged and informed
and to
and to you know without having to spend
40 hours a week on it
and uh and so like you know
to some extent it's like this is this is
terrible and and
very concerning and to some extent like
those things do have to exist we just
have to be
as citizens really aware of how stories
function and
and wary of how how they're going to be
used to manipulate us
[Music]
hiranyang speaks we're big fans of your
data being yours the fact is though
every time you surf the web people are
keeping track of you
and that incognito mode does not quite
do what you think it does
pretty much they're still keeping track
of you so how the heck can you truly
protect your data and go anonymous
online you can do
what the companies do use a virtual
private network and if you're going to
use
a vpn we recommend expressvpn
it's number one rated vpn by cnet and
wired who know what they're talking
about
and if you visit our exclusive link
expressvpn.com
you can get an extra three months free
on a one-year package that's
e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com
yang expressvpn.com yang to learn more
i literally use it to stream your
podcast videos
and music and netflix at the same time
it works
so i i don't know i don't know how often
you use it andrew i use all the time
it's fantastic expressvpn.com
yang try it
[Applause]
so if we look at these social media
platforms we say okay there are serious
problems with them
and i have a few policy proposals that i
put out on
the trail and we launched the data
dividend project which i just had this
long meeting about
and here's where it gets interesting is
where uh this is the story we're trying
to tell to your point
is like story one when you say to the
average american
hey your data is yours and you should
have data dignity
it's about like human autonomy and free
will and then an american will hear that
and be like yeah yeah i agree with that
um but then they but they won't really
do anything i mean it's like just
click on i consent uh you know use these
platforms and just
ignore and hope for the best because
like you said i don't have any time i'm
busy
yep yeah i'd rather trade my convenience
for my privacy any day
i'll take that deal so that was story
one
and a number of people have tried that
story and it yeah
has not gone anywhere yeah and then we
looked at it and said okay you know what
our story is gonna be
they are making tens of billions of
dollars a year off of you and your data
shouldn't you get some of that why don't
we just get you this data dividend
sign up here and we'll go fight for your
right to get paid for your data
and so i'm very excited about that
because i think that's a winning story
and we we've now had um tens of
thousands of people sign up
um in in the first week and we were
fighting on that side
and then there were some people that
came back and said hey
that isn't the policy goal you should
have
of people getting paid for their data
because they're not going to get paid
enough and
you know it's still going to continue
some of like the darker issues that
i think you're driving at um in your
book
and i looked at it i you know looked at
it was like
so you don't want us to try and get
people paid for
their data because you think there's
like a better policy that
frankly i wouldn't even necessarily
disagree with like if you gave me
the power to pass like a better data
rights policy that made it so these
practices were off the table
like i would be thrilled i would sign
that but yeah you know like right now
that's not
feasible like congress is not going to
take that up so in the meantime let's
like try to activate people around us
um so i i hear what you're saying that
like
a lot of what we're engaged with is
different appeals different stories
different story lines
uh thinking that somehow we're going to
be communicating
purely on a rational basis uh is
silly i suppose yeah yeah i mean i think
that
i think that there's a story to tell
around rationality for sure
and i think that that will resonate with
some people and not with others
and that's what happened with my
campaign hank where
like i started out communicating very
rationally and i think it attracted a
particular tribe
of people now that tribe was less than
51
so then we were looking around being
like okay like
how can we try and get someone else to
join
this truck we've got all the people
we're gonna get with this strategy
so let's expand the strategy yeah yeah
so so that was
one of the the things that i was engaged
with but to push a little bit further
so if you were in the room
with let's say members of congress or
the president
or something and they were just and i'm
gonna play act
um as joe biden let's say maybe i'll
pretend to be jokes sure why not
um it'll be easier than the alternative
yeah yeah i mean i think it's going to
be jones
so uh so joe looks at you
and says hank uh congratulations my
um you know grandchildren are fans of
yours
uh what should we do about these social
media platforms
uh to improve things uh for the next
generation
well i mean this is so the first thing i
think is that
there are anti-trust concerns here i
don't think that youtube and google
should be the same company
i don't know that google and android
should be the same company
i don't think that aws and amazon should
be the same company
i like that to me feels like
there's just too much consolidated power
there and it's interesting because like
i know some of the people high up at
youtube fairly well
i think that they're really good people
and i think that they believe that what
they are doing is the right thing for
the world
but what i don't believe is that
any unelected leader should have as much
power as they have
and and and it's not power over the
government it's power
over our lives and and so
i think that we need to make space for
there to be competition here
and if there are if there is a great
if there are these moats that are
created by these companies
like and maybe the the the anti-trust
isn't just breaking up or maybe it's
it's something other than breaking up
where you know
you prevent companies from buying
competitors which used to be a thing
like this used to be rules around this
you can't have them by competitors
to put them out of business um
or and you also just like can't like
just sort of like gobble up the people
who are going to
take your market share because like we
need
more than one and we need more than 10
ideally different companies in this
so that they can innovate different ways
they can create platforms that are going
to appeal to different types of people
there and like create um
you know tools that they wouldn't have
thought of and that are going to be
better
for folks now obviously there are
network effects when it comes to this
stuff like i upload stuff to youtube not
because i think it's the best video
platform but because that's where the
eyeballs are
and i i'm never going to change that
until the eyeballs are somewhere else
but i think that there are ways to
open that up and um
and and create and so i i think that's
that's the first thing
is to say how do we like recreate a
competitive landscape here
and whether that's breaking them up like
we did with uh
the bells or whether it's um
you know creating some kind of uh forces
against monopoly
because right now like it's great for
their stock prices like but like
there's no doubt in anyone's mind that
these companies are building really big
moats
and that they're getting you know
and they're building moats not just
around sort of customer interactions but
in
in some cases what i'm starting to
imagine is more citizenship interactions
where
we don't these aren't these aren't
companies we buy stuff from
they're companies who create the places
in which we live
and that's a very different dynamic than
like somebody who you know i'm buying
pants from
when when it's uh when it's in many ways
the the spaces on which uh
the the public discourse is had and in
places in which i sort of feel like i
live my life
that's actually a great observation
where
people i think think to themselves well
what's the big deal
like i go on these things and you know
they they reach me with
ads but you said it in a really profound
way it's like this is where you live now
you know like this is how you're
experiencing the world
this is how you're developing your point
of view
your world views and your values and
like your relationships
you know i have many many friends who i
know entirely through social media and
have never met in the real world i
started a business
that is now like i you know makes
millions of dollars a year with a guy
who i did not meet and for like five
years into running the business with him
and uh not not in the real world i mean
and that like
i i really do think that like we're
gonna eventually realize that these
companies
are more than companies and in a way
they are their own governments
and that like the board of facebook and
cheryl uh and and mark are like
the government of that company like
they're the leaders and that
we need to you know like there are
different ways to exert pressure on them
and like there's internal ways like
they're employees and there's
advertisers which we're seeing now
there's actual regulations from the
government
there's also pushes from users and
pushers from
pushes from like the creators who are
you know really big on the platforms
we need to start thinking about how we
uh like affect
the the governance of those companies
because they govern the spaces in which
we live
and and imagining and i do this you know
in the second book pretty
obviously imagining that these places
are are not companies but they are in a
way countries
is and they are countries that are you
know sort of totalitarian
autocracies like capitalist autocracy
presiding over his
2.2 billion yeah subjects
saying today you will see this
and you will like it and it will be good
yeah and and like the the algorithms now
are extremely sophisticated but i think
they're nothing like what they're going
to be
in 10 or 20 years and when i talk to
like well-meaning
uh business leaders in silicon valley
who are running these big companies and
and have a lot of
you know maybe more influence than they
realize they have
um i i kind of want to ask them like not
just like how do you make sure you do
this right but how do you make sure that
once you've consolidated
this much power in one place the person
who takes over after you're gone
how do you make sure they do it right
how do you make sure in like 50 years
when you know facebook looks a lot sort
of older and stodgier and it's
sort of like on its you know maybe on
its way out maybe their competitors and
they're trying everything they can
to to keep that shareholder value
increasing like what does that world
look like
not just what does the world now look
like and they don't really
tend to respond well with that question
i think it kind of scares them to think
50 years in the future
that's a great question for them you
know like that time scale
is foreign i think to silicon valley in
part because
you know how old is that company now
maybe right maybe 20 years old
yeah and uh what you said earlier about
the fact that
this is bad for innovation is
objectively true
i mean if if you were to start a company
today
and say we're going to be the next
facebook like you'd never get any money
but but if you were to say we're going
to get bought by facebook
then an investor would look at them
being like tell me more
that they look at it and say that's the
business model
yeah that that's the new business model
in silicon valley it's not even
uh to be truly a viable competitor like
hewlett packard
start in the garage and like become this
massive public company it's more like if
we play our cards right
we can squeeze 600 million out of google
and then we all go home happy and
some people get absorbed into into the
google mothership
and you're 100 right that we used to
have rules around some of these things
we used to look at and say you know what
you're buying that company not a good
idea
because you know it would just take you
to
to too much market dominance
and right now the markets these
companies operate in
are quite ill-defined where if you look
at
google and facebook they are built on
advertising and
our data and attention that's where most
their money is but
google in particular has companies in
everything you know they have like the
al
alphabet umbrella and then they they can
work on satellites and
self-driving cars and and uh all of the
apps that we use that
then end up feeding into the the data
and algorithms so that they're
there's a huge place for us trying to
apply some kind of 21st century
antitrust
framework but the single most obvious
thing would be like
guess what you can't just gobble up
every tech company
insight that is is anywhere touching
your space
like you're gonna have to get that stuff
cleared by us
and they just have so much money they
have more money than they know what to
do with
like the you know like they can buy back
their own shares so they could buy other
companies what else
like that and it's a little
disappointing because to some extent
like it felt like for a while that
google was a lot more
you know just try everything and go hard
and it feels like they're pulling back
from that strategy
um in favor of you know sort of like
concentrating on their core competencies
and
uh instead of being internally
innovative um
just sort of like making android better
making gmail better making
search better well most people don't
understand
just how vast the resources available
maybe they do now
but if you're a startup and you're doing
your thing
and then they just come and plunk down
like hey here's 800 million
in google stock or facebook stock you're
literally
going to be legally obligated to take it
in some cases like
you're like there'll be investors being
like hey fyi like
this deal is getting done like they
they almost have their own currency they
could use it's like facebook box
in the in the form of their stock
because they're worth 650 billion
dollars
so literally if they were to do a six
billion dollar
acquisition which is bigger than they'd
have to do um
like 600 million is something like a
tenth of one percent
of their value so they can actually make
those moves
and well and they don't they don't even
have to spend the money because capital
is so cheap
right now that like loans for facebook
and google are basically free money so
they could just they could just buy it
with money they don't even have
and it's not like any bank in the world
doesn't want to loan these companies
money
they have a hundred billion dollars in
cash on the books
they can pay back the loan yeah
they're they have their own money
machine it's wild yeah like
facebook's revenue is 70 billion and you
know it's like
i mean that that's all going going not
all of it but
most of it's going to the bottom line
like google it's
i think 160 billion uh so the mechanics
of these companies really
are unlike anything we've seen before
and there's nothing wrong with companies
making oodles of money
but when it starts creeping into a zone
where they're actually
controlling the way people live
perceive reality think vote
uh interact with each other um it's
it's impinging our ability to actually
have reasonable conversations live
healthy
lives and solve society's problems
meaningfully
because facebook to just to keep uh
using them because everyone understands
them uh is like facebook's economic
incentives are furthered
by us like uh being pitted against each
other
like it's actually better for them if
you have more sensationalist
points of view that get people ginned up
and it makes it harder for
for us to actually get anything done
yeah it's
it's it's a little terrifying when you
think like um
the uh just the the lack of regard for
which emotion someone might be
experiencing as long as it
increases the engagement on the platform
but it's also terrifying to think the
opposite thing that like facebook would
care what emotion i'm experiencing
and tried to have me experience a
particular one
and like i think right now facebook's
like whatever works
we'll do that uh whatever people like to
share whatever people like to click on
but if facebook
you know has also said a little bit of
like well what if
in youtube too like what if we think
about you know the
people's overall well-being on these
platforms then it's like okay so you're
saying you're going to have an algorithm
that's designed
to affect overall levels of
joy of happiness of satisfaction and
that's like
to some extent like i don't know like is
that good but also like
super potentially terrifying and
dystopian if you imagine these places
not as
companies but as countries they actually
released some research that said
hey fyi we make people sad
[Laughter]
they also release a research being like
hey we tweaked the algorithm and we
found that it increased sadness
they literally were like like it was it
was like this
um not very well publicized release but
like the implication was very very
uh disturbing
[Music]
this is a really tough time for all of
us we're all struggling
me included you know uh i mean
there are days when things seem
overwhelming when you look up
and think how am i going to necessarily
get through this next period of time so
if you're
having those sorts of feelings you want
to talk to someone and not just your
buddy
or someone who frankly is not
uh actually trained to help you figure
out what's going on with you
i go to better help because they can get
you
a licensed counselor professional
counselor who can talk to you within the
first day
they'll assess your needs and then you
can talk to someone
and hopefully get a rain on some of the
things that you're thinking and feeling
i saw a counselor for the first time
when i was a sophomore in high school
it was awesome then it's awesome now we
could all use help
and better help is a great way to find
someone who will actually help push you
in the right directions
and unpack what's going on inside so
many of us right now
so if you want to join over one million
people who are taking charge of their
mental health health you can go to
betterhelp
help dot com yang and you'll get a
discount off your first month
of using better help betterhelp.com
[Music]
never before has there been any way to
do
this much research on how on human
behavior
and the interesting thing is like as
long as that research is kept internal
to facebook there isn't a lot
that like is that is like ethically in
terms of like modern
you know academic ethics there isn't a
lot that you can say is like kind of
not allowed but if you did the same
experiments in an academic setting
it would be like the review board would
be like no way
no way would we allow you to do an
experiment on whether like
you know tweaking an algorithm made
people depressed
which might have like you know an
ultimate
like result of people dying um
if you're doing these experiments on you
know hundreds of millions of people
so the
that power is really amazing um and i
don't know that they've even begun to
really leverage it
and if they can figure out like what
what really concerns me is that like if
facebook figures out how to make people
happy
but then it turns out happy people use
facebook less um
of course like would they do that well
this was something and i loved how you
and your brother got started
where you you had this um video log
where
that's the way you communicated and you
said hey we're not gonna do all the
digital communications
it's clear to me that if you were to
design a facebook to maximize our mental
health it would involve less facebook
you know
like it's kind of like like like that
that's pretty
clear um and and i sense that it's
something that
you've balanced over the last uh
gosh 13 years where you have almost come
of age
uh as a creator like one of the original
digital creators you've done at this
point dozens of
uh of projects in different forms and
formats that have reached
tens of millions of people in various
ways
and i sense that you also have been
trying to reflect and
internalize what the heck it means to be
someone who uh is so highly visible
and and you know you you almost like
become
a dad and an adult like in in so it's
not not quite the public sphere but
you know like certainly more visible
than probably was possible at any point
in recorded history
prior and and
and whether that becomes like good or
bad
for your personal life your mental
health like that kind of work
and i'm going to to bring it back to
something you said earlier do you
you must have seen this so there's like
an episode of black mirror where
uh like this character played by daniel
kaluuya i think it was called 10
000 merits or something where he like
rages against the machine
and then at the end there were like that
was great
let's give you your own tv show and
then he winds up in like the thing where
um
where like and so that was like dark
but like relatable uh where it it feels
like you and i in some ways it's like
we're
we're calling out it's like look there
are real problems
with social media and these platforms
and the digitization and uh
commodification of ourselves and our
content and our data
um but then uh you know in my case i
spend a lot of time on social media on
any given day like you obviously have
like built like
these these tremendous followings
and i'll share with you my personal
thing is like i've actually been
trying to figure out how to best balance
it with my
own uh mental health
family life like parenthood being a good
dad
um and because for me i was not as
highly engaged with it when i was
running for president but when i was
running for president it was like
you know a pretty significant part of
like my my
job my role and then post campaign
um we've evolved into this other thing
where i'm still trying to make
all of the things happen that i was
trying to make happen before
but now i have a different balancing act
and so you've been at this for much
longer than i have and i'm
i'm just wondering whether you have
things to share with other people who
are
uh creatives and public and using social
media a lot
i do uh and do i have a book for you
it's this
this is the first one in the series um
yeah i mean that's
that's what i was trying to figure out
with the first book and
and i kind of came of age inside of it
but i was 27
when i started doing this i was i was
married i had had
a career uh already because like that's
how life works
um i'd been a chemist i'd you know i was
at that time i was um sort of trying to
make my way as a writer and a uh like
like freelance like tech help stuff
um so it's actually been much harder for
the friends
my friends who had this as their first
first job they were like 17 years old
when they started to get famous on the
internet
and it's even harder for people who are
sort of not
uh like not white dudes because like
there's a lot of
like a lot of uh
scary stuff that can happen when you're
especially like
for women on the internet uh who are you
know trying to make their way as a
creator i i've watched a lot of people
be
scared off of platforms
um and like i've also watched people go
through stuff that would definitely have
scared me off a platform but they stuck
with it and made it
made it happen um so like i think that
there's a
there's a lot of different levels of
hard to this
but um but now that like but but like
for like where we are which is that we
have
other sources of meaning in our lives
and this is one thing i say to creators
all the time is
diversify your identity like this thing
that's happening to you right now is
going to feel like the most important
thing
and it's really amazing like people are
giving you so much positive feedback
like instead of just having like you
know the 20 people in your life that you
care about
telling you that you're worthwhile
you're getting that from 20 million
people
and there's no way that those 20 people
who actually matter to you
can compete with that but you have to
you have to convince yourself that they
matter more
and you have to find other ways for for
like to value yourself because this
thing is extremely volatile
you never know where it's going to go
you never know when you're going to
start to hate it
or when it's gonna start to hate you and
so you like you have to have other other
places where you're getting meaning
other ways that you believe that you're
important in the world
and i think that you have that but
that's like my number one piece of
advice for people who are getting into
this and are just starting to be
successful because they completely start
to disregard all those other parts of
their life
and this happens in in the book because
like it's
something i've seen over and over again
and i wanted to show it happening
where it's just like nobody can compete
with this like no one person
can compete with this and like you're
holding me back and i'm just gonna i
gotta go
i gotta get out of this like i can't i
can't have you and my life holding me
back
has your book been optioned as a movie
because it sounds like it would be ideal
i took i i uh i said no to a bunch of
uh that early on because i wanted to
finish the sequel before i did it so it
hasn't yet but
it people were interested but i said no
now
there's going to be a two-part series is
there a is there a trilogy is there like
a whole arc i feel like no this is it
it's this is the two this is the two
books so it it was
always intended to be two books yeah so
now it's going to be a two-part movie
now the question is is it going to be
combined into one
mega film like lord of the rings part
one or is it going to be
like uh yeah like definitely two films i
mean i
i first of all it's 2020 andrew i don't
know if you know but
do films exist anymore oh they exist
they exist they're just gonna
more likely they're obviously more
likely to they're gonna take the uv
rays and just sanitize the crap out of
those sets man
it's gonna happen it's happening yeah so
it's more likely to be a tv show
honestly because most things that get uh
like
first of all insight into the novel
writing world
uh a lot of books get optioned of those
like
only maybe less than 10 actually get
turned into something
and then um and then like the the
process of like whether that thing that
like starts being developed actually
results in a thing that becomes public
it ends up like one percent of novels
actually turn into
things so probably won't be anything uh
but but most things these days are
getting turned into tv shows and that
was that's where a lot of the interest
was
in in this book so like a you know
like a 12 episode series
like two times maybe i have a prediction
that this is going to pass
and your books are going to be in that
one percent of novels that get turned
into
tv scripted entertainment i would love
that now that i'm done with them
i just couldn't think about it while i
was writing it it was too much
um and i just needed to focus there
would have been like a george rr martin
situation i didn't want to be one of
those i didn't want to be one of those
like it took me two years and that
is as fast as i could have done it and
i'm very proud to have done it and also
that it's getting really good reviews
um i was very you know i think it's easy
to get into your head
and think that you know there are a
bunch of problems with the book and and
there are always issues but like
the first reviews are in and they're
very positive and so i'm i'm
[ __ ] gliding right now i'm so happy
because it that period between when you
finish the book and the first reviews
come in is very scary
yeah writing a book is very personal and
you feel like you're putting yourself
out there
and you feel like any judgment about the
book is like a judgment on
you
like it's a it's a judgment on uh
having done it now myself like when when
you write a book
um it's very very hard to separate
yourself from that book
uh in terms of what people think about
it like if they think your book sucks
they're saying you suck
well and this is this is the thing with
all on create online creation now too
is because like the things you're making
are so often
not uh like not the thing but they are
like extensions of you and that can be
really really
scary for people well i'll tell you i'll
tell you man it's not like because like
if i may if i mean i don't do this but
like if i made it a video and people
were like oh that video sucked i'd be
like well whatever that video took me
like
you know like an hour or two but like if
if i spend like months and months
killing myself over a book and people
are like that book suck that it's not
like
you you misspent your hour
it's like yeah no it's a lot a lot this
is a lot that goes into the other thing
that i would say and that i think
i've been thinking a lot about is that
like we get i think that you and i
probably get hyper focused on
productivity to a certain amount just
judging by the amount that you have done
uh i would guess at that and one thing
that i've been working really hard on is
trying to
to recognize that like a a a product i
can produce is my own
happiness and that counts and that the
happiness of the people in my life
counts as productivity as well
um so that's a that's a piece that i
would give to you um
that i one of the characters in my book
realized for me
that as long as i think of productivity
as only including things that are
external to me
i will be unhealthy that is
a fantastic principle to live by that
should be like a life principle
someone's happiness including my own
counts as productivity
have you named this principle
i've not it was it was said it was said
by a character in my book i can't tell
you which one because it would be a
spoiler
then we should name it right now hank
this should be
it should be called like the happiness
as productivity principle
yeah like making yourself or someone
important to you happy
is productive yeah and i could not agree
with you more that hold on to it
yeah some people listening to this and
being like like of course [ __ ] like
what are you talking about
but yeah but but i completely can relate
and agree with i
agree with you on this and the the most
powerful example
is your child so one of my boys is
on the autism spectrum and there are
times when we're doing something
together
that is uh let's say
testing of one's patients or something
along those lines
and and then you feel if you're
like an efficiency fiend you're like hey
this is like a waste of time
and and then you have to be like wait a
minute like
this is actually perhaps the most
productive thing i can be doing
because you know it's going to to help
um my son experience the world a
particular way so
so that that's something that i struggle
with
um i struggle with
not on a daily basis but like you know
every so often
like so i'll be doing something with one
of my
boys and then i'll have like 15 things
like kind of gnawing at my brain where
it's like hey
you need to you know call this person
back or do this or do that
and you have to try and say wait a
minute like
this is actually more important than
that
right now and i need to start regarding
it that way
yeah absolutely it's something i
struggle with and have struggled with
as long as i've been a professional um
and that
and i i'm better at it some months than
others like it's not it's a it's a
process not something that i've like
finished with oh yeah you're never done
yeah but naming that principle certainly
is gonna help
so the name of the book is a beautifully
foolish endeavor and my question for you
is does someone need to have read the
first book in order to
get the second book yes unfortunately
but the first book is also great
and and in paperback so it's inexpensive
uh
also we i actually read most of my books
now
through audiobooks or listen um and uh
we worked really hard on the audiobooks
so that's a format that is very close to
my heart and that i
take really seriously and don't like a
lot of like a lot of
i was sort of surprised to find that my
publisher expected that that would be an
afterthought to me whereas it was like
the central thing you're like the
audiobook is the jam
yeah i want to think really hard about
how we do that and the name of the first
book is
an absolutely remarkable thing an
absolutely remarkable thing
so the experience of reading your book
into
so did they send you to a studio or do
you just have your home studio oh no i
didn't i didn't record it
i didn't do perform it you mean your
first book or your second book or just
the second book
i didn't perform either of them no you
had some freaking
other person read your book into audio
format yeah the book is
the book is is red is is from the
perspective of a
of a 23 year old woman i was not going
to record it
that makes perfect sense because it was
a novel so do you know how it was
recorded that did they have
yeah a young female or do they have
different characters or how does that
work if it's a novel
yeah so the first book uh so basically
the first book is written as a memoir
but of a fictional character and um and
a woman named kristen c recorded it
she's wonderful and she did a really
good job of like capturing
the like the main character who's very
sort of like
um uh
grumpy but funny kind of
uh is her her vibe maybe if i get
everyone
and and the first book uh was all from
the perspective of one character except
for the last
chapter which actually i did record
because it was from the male perspective
and then the second the second one is uh
was a lot more fun because we have five
different
characters who have who have point of
view chapters and so they all got to
record their own chapters
one of those characters is not human so
that was fun to deal with
um and uh and then there's also
uh interstitial bits so like like
they're called epigraphs so before a
chapter would start just some
context from the world and sometimes
those were like ap
articles but sometimes they were
podcasts like transcripts from podcasts
so instead of like speaking that like
this is a transcript from a podcast
instead we actually like recorded the
podcasts
as if they were the thing that you're
getting from the world
so interesting man yeah the reason why
it didn't hit me that you it would make
much more sense to have someone else
read it
um is that i've only written non-fiction
books and so anytime
it was happening it was like hey andrew
you want to go to the studio and
like this should only take you two or
three days and
and i and i i have to tell you
that the act of reading your entire book
into a studio which it sounds like you
have not had to do uh but they have
just a bit yeah but they literally have
every herbal tea and lozenge known to
man there for you
and you're just there and you're just
going to be like
reading for eight 10 hours in a row
and yeah and in my first part of sorry
no no no
in my case they were like hey this is
going to take you three days
um and i was like [ __ ] that [ __ ] i'm
going to get this
done in two days max because hell if i'm
gonna spend three days
reading i mean i mean i loved my book
and like i was happy to read it and i
thought it was important
like but like you know come on are you
kidding me like i'm gonna spend like 60
of a work week like just freaking
reading
so yeah so so it became like this thing
i was like two days max and like
and and then the efficiency uh
theme to me came out where i was like
why does it take so long
i did some math i was like i should be
able to get this done and they were like
oh it's because of an error rate
because it's actually very hard to read
error free
like for that sustained period of time
and i was like done
i will make no mistakes i am andrew yang
yeah that was like the that was the
mentality
yeah the the worst part for me was
reading so the chapters
i did read so i i've got a bit part in
the second book and a whole chapter in
the the first book
is that i wanted to change things and i
was like but i'm allowed
i wrote it so i can say it differently
and they're like no you have to do it as
written and i'm like
who says i am the author i get to
i can do whatever i want right and uh so
there was a bit of contention around
whether or not i could change things in
the audiobook that
were not exactly the same and i continue
to believe that it's fine
like that it's a different experience
it's a different genre it's a different
medium and
that like and there's a bunch of
circumstances where
i wrote basically an audiobook version
and a textbook version just be so that
like it would make more sense
well certainly if you're the creator and
you're used to having your
uh materials evolve over and over again
then for you having it be fixed seems so
bizarre you'd be like what do you mean
like i can't just tweak this thing who
cares um
yeah that is one of the magical things
about books you know it like becomes
sort of engraved as part of the
historical record
yeah once it gets published it i i you
know
it really does like it stops becoming a
a
fluid thing for me it does lock into a
space and become static
and and becomes real in a way that it
doesn't until i get the book in my hand
well congratulations on the awesome
reviews
i'm sure it's tremendous uh and it must
be a massive
joy to you to be at this stage where the
book is done
it's going to get into people's hands
people you like and respect are going to
read and enjoy it
and then yeah it feels really good and
all the people that read the first book
that want to see what like the next
uh the next chapter in the story is
yes it is very uh it was very important
to me and very exciting
to to uh there's a lot of mysteries in
the book and to
have them all wrapped up at the end
feels really good especially when that's
been
uh that has been denied me by some
fiction creators over the years
that the uh the mysteries never really
wrapped up and i was very
uh very committed to wrapping them up
myself that angers me as well so kudos
to you hank
because when they try and like
have these threads out there and then
the threads don't get resolved
satisfactorily
it's infuriating because it's like look
if i invested
enough time to give a crap about your
stories or your characters
then you need to have enough foresight
to figure out where this is going and
not leave me hanging
so so kudos to you
for not being one of those lazy
storytellers they make me so mad that
laziness
oh so mad it's been done to me too many
times
yeah and i i get it tv in particular
like they don't even know if they're
gonna have another season so they're
like
well hell if we know if anyone's gonna
ever see who killed sarah
or i don't know whatever it is we just
need people to be watching right now
that's all that matters yeah yeah and
like i think that that's what it is like
you
you you open up a mystery because it
seems really compelling and like the
viewer is like
i don't understand how they're going to
fix how they're going to make this make
sense and then it's like oh they're not
and like part of the reason i was
watching is because i wanted it to it's
like
yeah we just it's a betrayal summarized
the problem with social media and the
problem with modern capitalism
it's like it's like look all i care
about
is what number i'm getting right now and
so
like the downstream effects who cares
and it turns out we're still going to be
there like
x weeks from now and we all care
and you need to get your arms around
what the heck social media and these
platforms are doing to
like our our society our democracy our
mental health our way of life our
ability to interact with people
uh and and you can't be starting these
threads that you don't know where the
hell they go um that those things are
not of equal importance but i'm going to
to tie them together nice
agreed
[Music]
if you are anything like me the kitchen
is not
like the room that you are most
comfortable with in your home
uh like for me like i had one of these
got like cookbooks for guys
where they said like take your shoes out
of your oven was like the first step
because you were just using it to store
crap and you weren't actually
cooking i thought that was hysterical
but also a little bit too close to the
mark
in my case so if you are like me or
you're just time starved
there's a service called freshly that
will send you delicious
pre-prepared meals it's healthy it's
tasty
you don't need to go to the grocery
store and figure it out they'll just
send you a fully prepared
dinner delivered fresh not frozen right
to your door
it's healthy it's balanced it's got that
uh goodness like golden oven fried
chicken
or springtime risotto or deliciousness
that you didn't have to do
anything except subscribe to freshly so
if that sounds like your cup of tea and
it really ought to
uh freshly is offering our listeners 40
off for their first two orders
at freshly.com yang that's freshly.com
yang for 40 off your first two freshly
orders
yeah it's like yang speaks of buying you
a meal
uh so take a dinner on freshly
freshly.com yang so
i haven't told you this but the stove in
my apartment is busted
and they've given me a hot pan which
doesn't work and randomly like we'll
turn on in the middle of night which is
definitely a fire hazard so
don't use the hot pan don't use broken
stoves if you live in manhattan
or a city that has crappy apartments
order freshly
[Music]
freshly.com
[Applause]
[Music]
um have you been thinking a lot about
education lately because i have
yeah so i mean you've produced
educational content that has been seen
by
tens of millions uh you know you've
developed a real
knack for conveying concepts in a way
that people find fun and engaging
and right now there are so many families
and parents who are struggling because
their kids all got yanked out of school
and
we're all wondering what the heck is
next um so i would love to hear
what you're thinking well i mean can i
ask you first
like um you know i think that you
probably have a pretty pretty unique
perspective on
education also on education policy
that i probably don't have um
and and i have a lot of fear about what
secondary education or like what
post-secondary education looks like
right now what do colleges and
universities and community colleges look
like
um you know if we find that we cannot
gather in the same way
and like how do we interface with with
that with the problems that creates
because of course education is like
so fundamental to the foundation of like
all all of it like all of society all of
innovation all of like
progress so post-secondary
many colleges have no choice but to try
and reopen
uh in september because their finances
are constructed such that if they were
to not have a semester they would
go bankrupt and go out of existence
that's true for many many schools
including some high-end schools
there are only a handful of schools that
have these you know
big endowments and even the schools with
big endowments actually are operated in
a way such that it would be ruinous for
them to not
have a fall semester now the big
question is
how can you charge what you're charging
if all of it's online
and a lot of kids are struggling with
this right now where some kids
who have a choice which is not many of
them but are trying to defer
because they're like hell if i'm going
to have my
first year of college be this online
[ __ ] and i'd spend sixty thousand
dollars for the privilege of
attending class in my jammies and
whatnot like they're not into that
uh which is understandable but from the
from the school's perspective they're
like
the show must go on like the school must
open
and like many things
with the coronavirus there have been
problems building up in the system for
decades
where our colleges have been doing a
lesser and lesser job of actually
educating people or preparing them for
modern day uh life or the economy
especially per dollar spent
yeah well so here's the way the numbers
work for the for these colleges
uh if you look at the cost of various
things most consumer goods have remained
relatively stable in price
books electronics clothes like you don't
see the prices going up to the moon
so what are the exceptions to that the
two big ones are healthcare and
education
where healthcare just keeps getting
racked up and up and up
just like higher prices to the moon in
colleges every year like hey guess what
we're
you know four percent more expensive and
then you like compound that
and college now costs two and a half
times what it cost even then when i went
to college
right or when you went to school we're
like both in our 40s and we're probably
not that far apart so
so yeah um so then you if you're a kid
you're like okay i guess college is 50
or 60 000
now or you're a family um and then does
that mean that i get paid more on the
way out
no turns out opportunities completely
stagnant and i actually if anything i've
gotten rid of a lot of them
um so how the heck do i afford to go i
take out massive government loans and
the government's like don't worry we've
got you
so now we're up to 1.6 trillion dollars
in school loans
and families feel like well i have no
choice but to take it out because
it's college and uh you know uh
my kids got to go the kid's like well
clearly i'm going to college
and so then they they go they get loaded
up with this massive debt load
and from the college's perspective
they've been paid
they don't need to adjust particularly
and they just keep ratcheting up the
price every year
so if you dig deeper and you say well
why is college so expensive why is it
that
it has to go up in price it's not
professors
it's not even facilities which most
people would guess it's
non-academic administrators the number
of non-academic administrators and
colleges have gone up 150 percent
as prices have gone up they just keep on
hiring more
uh administrators yeah so and like a lot
of it's like
like a lot of money's being spent on
sales basically like to like we're
spending money to make money and that's
just increasing and like if but if you
don't
i i was watching a friend of mine go
through this process her kids going to
college and
like she was like i got this huge
booklet from this university in alabama
but
the university of montana i live in
montana so like the
local university only sent us like a
tiny little pamphlet and so i just don't
feel like
and i'm like no don't go to the school
that's spending all that money like they
sent you like a hundred dollars of
material
out of the blue with and like you know
chances are like 90 percent of those are
not going to result in
a sale or more than that so like their
customer acquisition cost is going to be
astronomical and that's what you as a
student are paying for
to acquire new customers for the
university go to the school that isn't
spending money
like it's spending money on [ __ ]
teachers not on on sales you know
and so so yeah watching
and and you know people in academia have
watched this happen
and they've been you know comfortable
the whole time
what just watching as school has become
closer and closer to not being worth it
and eventually you get to the point
where it actually isn't worth it anymore
and for a lot of majors i think you're
already there
where it unless you are unless you have
a ton of money you're not
uh like it's not gonna be worth it for
you to go to school
it's not gonna be worth the loans and
like
it's it's such a and it's it's in the
same way as healthcare it's like so
depressing because this is like the one
like one of the fields where it's like
this is supposed to be all about helping
people
and like it should be this like really
great
good public good public service job
but like more and more professors kind
of can't feel that way because of how
much it costs
they're lucky enough to become
professors man because you have all of
these phds who are in like the permanent
post-doc
adjunct hell where they're going to get
paid subsistence and
there's no future and it's like hey yeah
tough luck like uh you know we just keep
minting
phds and there are no jobs for you
yeah and the and but and that's what's
keeping the level of like
how much professors are uh cost to
university that's what
that's what's keeping it level lots of
professors lots of tenured professors
are making a ton of money
but on average it hasn't increased
because you've got all these
adjuncts and you've got all these people
who are never going to get tenure and
just like getting paid very you know
the basic basic livings or not not even
a full living
like the teaching of students is not the
primary expense at a lot of these places
let's put it that way you know
making sure that yeah you know your kid
has some world-renowned expert teaching
them
yeah it's it's really immoral
uh what's gone on and it's in the guise
of like you said like a public good and
a non-profit in some cases
literally public institutions uh yeah
you know
we've really lost our way in so many
in so many respects and education
healthcare i think are like the two
that affect the most people that
everyone can understand that the third
one
is housing that's the other source of
inflation but it's not as extreme as
healthcare and education in most and in
some places it is but it but still a
huge crisis yeah yeah it's it's
it's not as extreme in like where you
are in montana like there's certain
metro areas where
it's it's as extreme or more extreme
yeah
yeah and you know
what really frustrates me is i think
that like there's no doubt in my mind
and i've always said this as somebody
who
sort of teaches uh through the internet
i've always said that like there is no
replacement for the classroom and like
that's not what we're trying to do with
crash course
we have no interest in that and i
believe that that there's no replacement
for the classroom
except that like now you have to now now
you're replacing the classroom there's
like no choice because that that kid you
must replace
and so like you have to adjust that
statement to say like there's no
system that is as good as the classroom
but there are other systems
and if you're gonna charge sixty
thousand dollars a year for the
classroom
and other people can find ways to charge
six thousand dollars a year
for an education without the classroom
then you lose the classroom
which is the best way to teach people
but you do lose it
like you lost it anyway and uh
because because we had to find a
different way because it just cost too
much money
yeah this is the crisis that many
universities are struggling with right
now and i think that
they're going to be able to bear it for
one season um though a bunch of the
marginal schools will close even now
it's like just like if you look around
the country
thousands of retailers are closing
thousands of right theaters are closing
tens or hundreds of thousands of
restaurants are closing i'm sure
hundreds of schools are closing uh not
not the big wealthier ones or the the
major public ones
um they can stand it for one season
but depending upon how long this drags
on for you're going to see
more insolvent schools pretty quickly
because a lot of
families are going to look up and say
wait a minute like this makes absolutely
no sense
for us to be paying this kind of tuition
do you have uh advice for kids who are
graduating right now
i say kids but they're you know i i mean
like uh
getting like this was their last
semester of college
so like welcome to the job market it's
coved
yeah this is a very hard time to be
looking for a job that is for sure uh
and so
a lot of it would be around
trying to find any way in which you can
contribute and develop
that may or may not be in the field that
you're thinking of it might not pay what
you want the living situation might not
be what you want
but just as long as you're growing at
all
professionally you should feel good
about it
like don't think oh i really want to get
into politics so i have to like make
sure it's like
the perfect job in that space like no no
just if you can find anyone that
will give you a chance to lend a hand
just freaking go for it and if that
and that's going to be hard too just
like even that's easier said than done
so it would be about trying to find ways
to make sure you're still
developing in some respect even if
you're trapped at home
for like a while uh you know making
schedules for yourself
like setting goals for yourself that are
achievable uh reaching out to people
even when you don't feel like it because
it's very easy to become somewhat
of a shut-in i think during this time
for a lot of folks
but you have to continue to try and put
yourself out there
uh i don't have great advice one of the
things i will say though is that
if you have time like you're in better
shape where like if you're a young
person
you'll be able to uh have this be
like an early bump in the road but it's
not going to define your whole journey
like that the people i'm most concerned
about are folks where
you know they spent 10 years working on
some uh
restaurant or bar food truck that now is
like completely kaput
you know like it like that that stuff
breaks my heart because
yeah i'm like you hank like i love
entrepreneurs i love
people who are actually trying to make
something positive happen
and this crisis is going to do a number
on
entrepreneurs uh to a higher level than
if you've got some
corporate job that lets you work from
home yeah absolutely
yeah and it's it's so hard and so
rewarding
when it's working um but when it's not
working
it is very hard to it's very hard to
work through failure um
and like not just while it's happening
but afterward and i think that the
important thing to know is
like one hopefully everybody gets that
like this is no one's fault
well i mean um that like
your failure was not your fault in this
circumstance um
but and and also that like um
you know that like one of the things one
of the really great things about making
your own
your own project investing in like
taking your money and spending it on
your dream instead of someone else's is
how much you learn and you can take
those skills other places
and you know management bookkeeping like
entrepreneurs
do everything and so there there's a lot
um
like i think that they they are good
hires and and also there are other
opportunities and other futures
and uh there's going to be a lot of need
for entrepreneurs and innovation
as we find new ways to
operate um whether that's about
coronavirus specifically or if it's just
about the world continuing to change
so we need people with those skill sets
we need people with broad skill sets
who are curious and passionate and want
to
make the world better oh one thing i
think you and i can both relate to
is that if someone beamed in and looked
at me in my 20s they'd be like
this guy's struggling you know like my
first company went bust
another company that uh ran out of money
and like another one didn't achieve its
goals and
i would be like what is this guy doing
you know so it took me
until i was uh 30 or so before i started
really hitting my stride in any
um professional growth or momentum i
mean i was growing
but it was like growing in the school of
hard knock so i was growing by getting
like knocked around
so so it's one reason i try and let
young people know it's like look you've
got a long time horizon because
uh you know like for me when i was 25
my first company failed i owed 100 000
plus in
school loans and so uh you know anyone
who looked at me at that point would be
like this guy's
sunk but
um so i know like
if you have time to recover and build
like i mean young people have more of
that than
than most anyone yeah yep
i think as long as you're learning at
you're winning look at you now too man
i'm sure when someone saw you and your
brother
like video blogging in 2007 you'd be
like what are these jokers doing what
the hell is this
i thought we were killing it i thought i
thought back then i thought
like we were doing something so amazing
and then i looked back at like my tax
returns from 2007 and i'm just like
how did i survive
how was i well i guess not how did i
survive but how wasn't i freaked out
like i should have been freaked out
because like making making you know
i just graduated from grad school and
i'm making 17 000 a year and i'm like
why am i not why am i not more scared
right now but i was just like
this is gonna this is gonna matter this
is gonna be a big deal and i was
i don't know why i believed it but i did
well you you believed correctly because
look at you now
but yeah it is funny those times when
you're like scrapping and scrapping and
like you've got this little kernel of
value
and then you're like look at my kernel
look at this
this kernel will grow into a mighty
popcorn tree or whatever the heck it is
certainly i felt that way any number of
times in my career i felt that way about
the campaign where i was like
look at my little presidential campaign
it will grow strong and true
uh and and there have been times when i
i in my life i've been like look at my
little dot-com
stroke of genius like this is going to
go someplace and it did not
you know yeah like it'd be like
absolutely
so when you you hold up like the kernel
of value like sometimes it goes
someplace great
and uh other times it doesn't but
you know if if you persist and just keep
uh working with good people i don't have
so many friends who like
they you know had like a dud except they
met someone really cool
through their dud and then someone
thought well of them and then called
them up and was like hey
uh you know right i wanted to work with
you like let's find something else to do
yeah yeah well hank congratulations on
everything congratulations first and
foremost on being such
a world-class creative and force for
making our kids smarter and stronger and
healthier
uh and on the new book that soon to be
turned into a tv show on
netflix it sounds like well i will wish
that into the world
thanks uh yeah and and on being a dad
and on
uh like on reflecting the fact that
making yourself
and the people you love happy is
not just a good thing but it's actually
the ultimate form of productivity
yeah well thank you so much for chatting
with me um impressed by you and all the
stuff that you do keep up it keep keep
up the good work
keep making it happen man yeah you too
man all the best of the family
thank you for listening in i hope you
enjoyed this conversation if you did
please do subscribe to yang speaks and
click on notifications so we can let you
know
every time we have a new episode